you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to the game spot co-op
stage here at e3 i am your host Chris
waters here to kick off a excellent
segment of discussions with these fine
fine folk sitting with me on the couch
to my right let's go down the line and
introduce them first we have and Renee
hello you're welcome to stage thank you
so much for having me very exciting III
2016 busy three for you so far yeah I've
been doing a few things alright
excellent and now we've got iJustine get
on the line I'm so excited it's so much
fun so far pretty good show huh yeah and
all the end jeff cannata yeah this is
awesome what a amazing group of people I
get to hang out with and talk fun games
it's very cool you've got a bunch of
different folks to chat with up on this
stage yeah if I happen don't tell them
this is my favorite just gave up the
secret all right today's discussion at
least the first of our many discussions
today will be how do you sell VR to a
non-believer on our couch we have one
person who tried a lot of ER she did not
like VR until very recently well gets
that first but Andrea let's talk about
your experiences with VR up until your
recent game changer okay sure so I've
been testing in demo in VR like a lot of
other games press for a couple of years
starting with you know the early
prototypes of the rift from oculus and
then getting into Morpheus and vibe so
I've done all different kinds of
experiences over several different
iterations that's very promising and
I've spoken at length with Jeff on his
podcast DLC about how I just don't I
don't quite get it it's like he calls it
magical and I was like I don't need that
in my life like its she hates magic
everybody I don't hate magic I just for
me it was something that it seems the
barrier to entry was so high and there
wasn't an experience to me that said
this is why I need it because after like
ten minutes
the headset on I was like I just want it
off for me when I sit down for a long
gaming session we're talking like six
hours seven hours you know like I can
never imagine doing that what the hell
is a big factor and I'll talk about more
of the barriers in just a sec but first
I want to get Justine and Jeff I want
you guys to talk about your sort of
general stance on VR as it stands now oh
I mean I love it I mean I remember even
doing a demo what it was like one of the
first oculus versions it was like duct
taped together I was like is this safety
and using that it's something but you do
have to get used to even like you were I
mean I think we all remember Google
glass for like even that process of
getting used to wearing something you
know you have to ease into it because I
did a couple demos here and i got really
motion sickness because it's something
that affects you physically and mentally
and it confuses the hell out of your
body like I'm not standing in front of a
person right now I'm actually safe
sitting in my room but I think that is
gonna be kind of interesting especially
for people who might not be that aware
of their surroundings and now they're in
this crazy world but I think what really
sold it for me was he was maybe the last
like a year and a half ago I did one of
the vibe demos I don't like this is
awesome and that was it is I really do
see this and even doing some of the
demos here I mean it's just really kind
of takes you into this whole other level
and playing with your friends but in VR
yeah I'm social in VR is gonna be yes
real life over it so it was at this very
event I think what four years ago three
years ago that there was this like
murmur around the show floor that
upstairs in one of the meeting rooms
there was this company Occulus they
weren't you heard about him on
kickstarter and but they had a demo here
and you you have to try Jeff you have to
try and I was like okay well let's see
if I can get in it was like everybody
was talking about they weren't taking
appointments it was just this like the
thing that everyone was like oh my god
you got to go there so we go up there I
we get in and you know the guys who make
that that crazy MMO Eve they cobbled
together this demo in like two months
and it has nothing to do with being an
MMO it's like this just trying just try
it we put it on and I'm in the cockpit
of a spaceship and I look down and
there's my body and I move my head on my
body moves and then the spaceship
launches i'm in space and I was like
it's over here we're here
we have done it we don't sheave the
thing I always dreamed of like I feel
like I need to be able to see my hands
and my feet and to actually feel like
I'm in it like that was the first thing
ever even trying oculus I'm like I can't
see the rest and it's not all matching
up I think that also really messes with
your mind a lot well oculus is showing a
recoil at their booth and it's a very
simplistic sort of a Tron throw things
back in point it's almost like human
foosball where you like move your body
in front of a goal to try to block
things yeah throw back and forth and it
has full body ik hello based on the
touch controllers and your headset it
can map your entire body including your
legs so if you squat down your legs
actually squat down it's it's really
amazing Wow yeah Jeff I can infer from
context but what is ik stand for I don't
know uh inverse kinetics I can't
remember yes let us know it means that
they built a full skeleton that if you
move this the rest of the skeleton moves
as well oh man yeah ah yes buttocks
what's it called I don't know that's
another thing that's kind of scary to
like on the vibe you got this huge cord
that's kind of like hanging off the back
of your head so unless somebody else is
in the room making sure you're not gonna
like kind of trip over that there's this
data there's a lot of hurdles but they
still have to go over is insane yeah
built across the paintings yeah but it's
so what you had to build an apparatus
and I hacked an ikea lamp looks like a
vision growl now you would look like the
fish dangling on the hook playing VR the
birdie boxes you get a really high
tripod and just mount the things on it
that's cool too yeah i totally would
work alright so we've talked about some
of the sort of stumbling blocks and made
you really sick Justine and I it's not
comfortable to wear an h md on your head
for a long time and not to mention the
fact that you get like oculus face
exactly a long time that doesn't go away
immediately I but you know so these were
some of the reasons also the experiences
so far in terms of games we've seen for
VR you know II Valkyrie is i think is an
exception most of the stuff is much
smaller in scale so it seemed a dreidel
like you were saying that you know it
just that the experiences weren't quite
justifying that all the expense and all
the hoopla around it yeah
that's what my biggest complaint about
VR was that it's not only is it
expensive it's difficult to set up in a
lot of cases it's difficult to use so in
order to like overcome all of that you'd
have to have an amazing piece of
software you sara lee have to be a game
it can be an experience i think some of
the most interesting virtual reality
experiences are just that they're not a
game there you know that underwater demo
that you know we've seen on a couple
different platforms was really neat i
keep going back to that one the blue
yeah exactly and other things like that
that to me were ru very unique thing and
there just wasn't that one thing until
today until today oh yeah Andrea finally
had a moment with we are I had my
moments give it to us what do you got so
at the PlayStation press conference on
Monday night Rocksteady and Warner
Brothers unveiled Batman Arkham VR and
everyone the audience of course was like
on my rock space to working on Batman
yeah um so I managed to like sneak my
way into a demo room earlier today thank
you Warner Brothers for fitting me in
and it blew my mind okay like I was not
ready and I think a lot of it also has
to do with holding the controller Anna
no vive has them in oculus now has the
touch controllers and I think that
without them like holding a traditional
controller breaks the immersion for me
holding like the each hand like seeing
Batman's gloved hands putting on the
cowl you know and it's the cowl and you
put it on and then there's a mirror and
then you're like I'm Batman I dance
maare it wasn't so it was so fun and
that you are put into this detective
scenario where someone has been killed
I'm not gonna say spoilers and you have
to figure out what happened and so you
don't in the Arkham games of the
detective mode you can rewind and kind
of like highlight something and
reconstruct what happened in the scene
you're doing that in the world you're
walking up to it you're rewinding it in
real time and living through the
cutscene okay and it was I can it's all
around you it's index
we manipulating things at any time you
want Chris you can pull out a Batarang
from your belt and throwing that's
anytime you want yeah I didn't get a
chance to do that demo but I did do the
Resident Evil One and that's where I
felt a little bit a little sick after it
because you are so brave like I will not
even attempt it OVR dev out it was so
the demo was so awesome though I mean I
was so involved in this whole story like
to the point where like one of the guys
that was like standing next to me that
was like talking and like oh we're
having a good day like he got too close
to me like I was actually uncomfortable
that I can feel him next to me and it
was just really cool because you really
do feel like you're there which is
almost terrifying because every little
thing I was super scared and this was
only the demo so I can't even imagine
what actually it was really were the
controller right you were was in the
control and I think that also is
something that kind of made me a little
bit nauseous is because I was moving to
controller and moving my head really
really fast so I think when you do first
jump into these things you have to take
it slow and I jumped in full speed ahead
I got going around running like an idiot
so I think that's something that is
gonna be a huge barrier is like how much
can you handle and how do you work into
it well I play I got him a chance to
play the fallout 4 demo you talking
about yeah and the way they get around
the nausea factor that there's a way
that a lot of games that are currently
available on vibes do it which is
teleportation your teleporting very
short distances and there's something
for whatever reason the brain doesn't
get bothered when you sort of flash to
something as long as it doesn't smooth
movement you know that flash but then I
played far points over at the Sony but I
don't know you guys have tried that yet
but it's a full-on first-person shooter
it's got that new gun peripheral yeah
and there's a thumb stick on the gun
peripheral and you you move that and I
was not nauseated at all um strafing was
a little bit scroogie vibe get over that
pretty quick and it's amazing like I'm
in a first person shooter full-on
excellent first person shooter shooting
stuff moving quickly it's here all I
know you kind of go with that it's not
here yet it's come here to it it's here
technically yes it's here at e3 putting
us in the hard part 2 they let barrier
to entry there hasn't been content it
hasn't been easy to get the headsets it
hasn't been easy to set them up so I
think this is sort of the year where it
is really it will eventually really
click beat critical mass where
everyone's like oh yeah I got one come
on over I'm telling you guys I you know
I went saw the call of duty demo and
I've seen a couple of other you know
dishonored and stuff and I'm sitting
there and I'm like you know we've spent
so long with these games trying to
create a feeling of being a first person
and like when they fall you see the hand
come up or a guy raised his wrist and
they're trying so hard to give you that
feeling of being there and I'm like in
five years none of these games are gonna
be on a 2d surface none of them you
don't think there's gonna still be a
market for free jewelry yeah I'm with
Andrea might maybe five years is
ambitious but at a certain point it open
seemed ridiculous that you're looking at
I still I I wholeheartedly disagree with
you on that I do because it's still way
too easy and convenient so just like if
I'm playing a game the doorbell rings I
put my controller down I walk over there
if you're in VR first you probably won't
even hear the doorbell ring or you won't
you know what people with kids people
have pets people with roommates like
yeah I don't think it'll ever be this
magical world that you think it's going
to be I think water days always gonna be
a thing you double-click the vibe and
all of a sudden I see that front facing
cameras view and I can that's the only
thing yeah but you're still tethered
with super junior honestly but i love
the augmented reality so I know we've
haven't heard anything about hololens at
all but that was one of the things with
it really kind of like this is it like
you're still living in this world you
can turn it on and off like the vibe but
like having the world around you sort of
feel like it's something different yeah
I love it well we're different degrees
of sold on the couch even though
Andrea's had that moment where you know
BR is the thing it works but not maybe
not in your household just yet very I
this one yeah I I have really enjoyed
some VR experiences my favorite
personally honestly has been the
experiences of just being underwater
just those experience like watching a
blue whales go by
like those transported if moments not
even the game specific ones have been
the best for me but of the game specific
ones i mean the vibe with the hand
controller so the oculus touch stuff you
got to have the hands like you were
saying earlier just eat it now my last
question for you guys as we sort of come
to the end of the segment is we saw vr
on stage at the sony press conference at
the ubisoft press conference they're
people trying to sell VR of course the
inherent issue is you have to see it to
believe it right but putting that aside
what do you think companies have done
right or what do you think there are not
doing well in order to sell their VR at
e3 hmm well I think one of the things
they're doing right is letting people
try it and you're hearing about a lot of
these initiatives of we're gonna be in a
Best Buy we're gonna be in a truck
touring around the country letting
people try it and as you said seeing is
believing and I think the more people
that have an experience where they're
like oh I get it now they tell two
friends and they tell two friends you
know and and I think really that's gonna
be the the selling point but also having
experiences like Batman and star wars
that sound cool you know it's one thing
for me to talk about how there's this
amazing game called I o moon where
you're in this pod and you're traveling
to her spit it's like okay but it's like
no you put Batman's head on and now
you're Batman it's like now that I want
to do no yeah it has to be those real
life experiences where you actually do
try it because until you do like you
don't have any concept of what that
feeling is like of being transported
somewhere else I mean you're still in
your body but you're not like it really
is so hard to explain so I mean even
things as simple as like Google
cardboard mm-hmm it's so simple and so
easy but you can still sort of get that
small taste of like what it's sort of
like how do you feel when you see for
example a bunch of people on the Ubisoft
stage they're all wearing the headsets
and they're doing this oh yeah yeah
would you like that I've got a
presentation I think that realistically
like I mean no one's gonna be probably
watching you and your friends but I
that's such a like cinematic experience
having
that many people playing VR at the same
time I know that a lot of people on
Twitter got really angry right away like
of what's that like a six thousand
dollars set up between all those people
with their PCs and our headsets all
playing Star Trek together like how
realistic is it that you have that many
friends who are all like VR acquits I
mean announcer it's gonna be so much
cheaper so it is I mean that is gonna be
the next step I mean I believe it for
though just curious like because gaming
now has been around for several decades
yeah but it's still not cheap to be a
gamer no but you know you don't
necessarily have to have four of
stations in your house you know if your
friend buys one or you you even if it
has good matchmaking yeah I don't know
you say it looks silly doing this yeah
you look like idiots this crap that's
fair that's fair i'm not i'm not one of
these self-conscious VR people at the
game spot office we put googly eyes on
the outside of all our headsets just
because like yeah look you're gonna look
goofy you might as well look extra goofy
doing it but I do think that what the
companies did well this year was show
those experiences that the Batman thing
the x-wing thing like that resident evil
defect and talking about fallout which
is a full game you're going to be
playing in VR I think they're coming
more around too okay we're at a point
where we have games full on games that
we can put in VR and that's what's going
to sell it because we are selling this
to gamers after all and it's not like
they were just trying to sell a short
stuff I honestly believe that there's so
much that it designers have had to go
back to Ground Zero and reinvent very
basic parts of how games work in order
to make them work in PR and we're just
at a time frame where we're finally
catching up to they've had enough time
to make bigger experiences now so it's
really it's really gonna ramp up hockey
stick style and we're gonna have awesome
stuff in like just a few months it's
it's such an exciting time I'm so
excited yeah first five Andrea still
holding out I'm still holding out no
Batman was great I loved it what's
happened what's the holiday good for you
do you think is it gonna be a flight
experience in or it's gonna be something
okay something that will throw up right
away
um you know I don't know I always told
people like when VR first was announced
in a couple years ago the first thing I
immediately went to was like if they
make Skyrim VR I'm done you know but I
don't know like obviously that's not
happening there working on the room at
elder scrolls oh yeah Scott we women we
are they're gonna get fallout in br
that's very a real possibility so maybe
then maybe in like what it was mobile
will that be like 20 20 you think it's
not near still it's so exciting it's
comin the VR whether it's here or
whether it's coming folks vr is a part
of our gaming life and it's great to
chat with you all get your perspectives
on it we will be back live in just a
moment folks talking about call of duty
infinite warfare don't go away